Well,
what Star Wars does is it tells us about
parents and children and uh,
how connected each is to the other.
And it is probably the most stirring
tale I think of a boy's need for a dad
and a dad's need for a boy that we have
in modern culture.
And it kind of nail some of the
intensity of those feelings.
It also,
and I think this is equally deep,
uh,
tells us something about redemption.
So the idea is that,
uh,
if you can get your kid to love you,
it's probably going to be okay.
And also if you do something heroic and
good,
uh,
you can probably be redeemed in some
sense of your soul,
whether we're talking about religion or
nod.
You can be redeemed even if you were,
uh,
really a creep before that,
at least if what you do,
they redeemed yourself is very major and
important as it certainly wasn't star
wars.
I think we're going to see themes about
parents and kids and redemption in the,
uh,
in the new episodes as well in terms of
empires and,
um,
republics.
Um,
what the movie's kind of capture.
And I think nail is that
authoritarianism,
uh,
has a bit of an appeal.
The idea that,
you know,
an authoritarian leader can get
something done,
then maybe take a little bit of the
chaos,
the freedom creates and uh,
get it into some sort of manage
management and that can make life a
little more orderly and people like
that.
But it also tells us that in every human
heart there is a kind of a need for
freedom,
meaning there isn't going to be a boot
on your face and there's going to be a
capacity for governor yourself and the
tail of the appeal of authoritarianism,
which really kind of captures what
happened in Nazi Germany and captured a
little bit some of the appeal of
authoritarians all over the world,
including,
uh,
currently a Turkey.
And it gets that.
And it gets that in a way that is true
to the arc of human history and the
failures of authoritarianism because of,
um,
people don't like him food in their
face,
it kind of lightly,
but,
um,
uh,
but memorably captures that as well.
So if you're in a,
you know,
a country that's poor and where people's
property rights aren't secure,
or are you go on the streets and someone
might beat you up.
Or if you're in a country that's doing
pretty well,
like the United States and some European
nations,
but terrorism is a risk,
or if terrorism is unlikely,
uh,
still,
you might get something stolen or
somebody might knock out because there's
violent crime or even if it doesn't
happen to you,
if you read it about the newspaper,
then you might think,
uh,
law and order is a pretty good,
corrective.
And even if law and order means that
civil liberties and civil rights will be
reduced,
maybe that's a trade you will be willing
to take.
And we certainly saw that in the United
States at times over the past,
let's say 40 years.
And while in the United States,
in my view,
nothing really horrific has happened in
terms of the rise of authoritarianism.
The fact that there have been movements
away from civil rights and civil
liberties is suggestive of something
that's possible when people feel really
at risk.
So what Star Wars captures,
and this makes it transcend the kind of
simple dichotomy between the light side
and the dark side of the force is it
says that,
you know,
uh,
the dark side,
it does have a seductive power either
because it means that each of us can
wield power if we go dark or because it
means that,
uh,
somebody at least is going to be
controlled in control of human impulses,
uh,
that can,
um,
uh,
threatened us.
And if the controlling power is
reflecting those forces,
that's not so good.
But,
uh,
some people would rather live in an
orderly society that is not a day to
day,
let's say,
a unraveling than a society that is free
because freedom,
uh,
suggest the possibility at least of a
little unraveling.
Mm.